You're an Avenger
have I killed you
before, they all blend together
after a while.
You're not the one with the hammer
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
This will be my Full Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania breakdown
Easter eggs for the entire movie.
There's so many references.
A bunch of teasers for Avengers
five Kang Dynasty.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There'll be a bunch of stuff
happening in the next couple of weeks.
Careful postponements of the movie
if you haven't seen it yet.
We'll start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot,
Talking about Easter eggs, moments
and how everything connects.
The movie is meant to be the official
beginning of Marvel Phase 5.
Kevin Feige basically said
that it is the beginning of the next
Avengers cycle, even though technically
that was Marvel phase for Marvel.
Phase four is more about
then trying a bunch of different things,
introducing some new concepts,
some new characters.
This movie is
when things really get going,
and that's why they use Kang the Conqueror
as the main villain
and the Council of Kings
because they are called
the Dynasty of Kings in Avengers
five is literally called Avengers
Kang Dynasty.
So it's like the New Avengers
versus the Council of Kings.
So Marvel, Phase five, Marvel Phase
six is when things really get going.
They have a brand new Marvel Studios
intro logo where they added assuring her
Black Panther suit right next to Ms
Marvel Falcon in is Captain
America suit also right after Shuri World
by night is also in here too.
Pretty much everybody who debuts
gets added to like the next movie
or series title.
Like they update it
after every single series and movie.
I also didn't see him before, but he who
remains Loki is now inside as well.
I don't remember
seeing he who remains in the title
before the actual opening scene,
tells the story of how Janet Van Dyne met
Kang the Conqueror and what happened
when he crashed in the Quantum realm.
She looks like she'd been living there
for over 10 to 15 years,
so she's a little bit more gray,
but not totally gray.
Like she's not quite as old.
And she explains that
after she destroyed his engine core,
she went on the run and live
with the freedom fighters
and fought against him for a long
time, too.
Wayne King crashes.
He crashes in his personal time ship.
It's based on the one from the comics.
It looks kind of like a clamshell.
Later,
we find out that he is Kang the Conqueror.
He is the Kang who started
the original Multiverse war.
He was originally on the Council of Kings,
one of the rulers
there are four statues
and he remains still at the end of time.
One of them is broken.
The broken statue is meant
to represent him when they exiled him.
When he says the other members
of the council, he's
talking about
the other variants of himself.
There are thousands of different variants
on the Council of Kings, but there are
always a couple of the most powerful ones
ruling over the council.
It's a mortis Rama Tut in what looks like
the MCU version of Scarlet Centurion.
Even though he looks like he's purple,
he says they're afraid of him.
They just didn't like his ideas.
So they basically exile him to the quantum
realm because exist separately from time
and space, meaning that it's protected
from changes of the timeline and protected
from things like Infinity
Gantlet snaps later when he says that
he knows how everything ends
and he wants to
prevent this coming calamity
and kill the rest of the Council of Kings.
He references the events
of the Loki series with
he who remains in the sacred timeline,
and then after that
he shows more incursions.
Loki shows what happens
after the end of the Loki series.
Like I've seen how everything plays out.
There's a version of the multiverse war.
Then he remains winds up winning using
Elias, he creates the sacred timeline.
That's what
the circle represents that he holds up.
Then when he holds that up, that's meant
to represent after the events of Loki.
When they kill, he who remains.
Thank you very much, Sylvie and Loki.
And he starts talking about the incursions
starting to happen.
He's basically
talking about what's happening
during Marvel phase for Marvel Phase
five right now
and how it leads into Avengers
Kang Dynasty again, in Avengers
Secret Wars in the comics, Kang
the Conqueror is born Nathaniel Richards.
That's his real name.
He's biologically related
to Reed Richards and Doctor Doom
during his time in the 30th century.
There's no disease,
no hunger, no want for anything.
It's like the most boring time
to live ever.
Nothing interesting ever really happens,
he finds a doctor doom museum in a doom,
but then somehow reactivates
and then unearths his library
and finds his plans for his ancient time
travel device.
The doctor Doom created.
He makes it better
and then uses that to go back in time
and become the Rama
Tut version of himself.
And then eventually the Fantastic
Four find out
they fight him, chase him to the future.
He takes the Kang
the Conqueror name, then returns
fights the Avengers in present day,
and so on and so forth.
Throughout his timeline
just takes different names
and keeps coming back to fight
The Avengers.
The difference in the MCU
is that they're seeing a lot of these
different versions of Kang
are different variants of Kang.
So like in this Kang's timeline,
he only became Kang the Conqueror.
They play a little fast and loose
with the way
the time works in the quantum realm,
because in previous movies
they made it sound like time moved faster
in the quantum realm.
So how does everybody remember
Janet Van Dyne
When they go back down, they're like,
No time has passed.
Like very little time has passed.
I think they're just kind of
hand-waving over that, saying,
You know what, don't worry about that
too much.
We go back to present day
post Avengers Endgame in San Francisco.
Everything's going great.
Also where she lives, he just lives
in a different part of the city.
The movie is meant to take place
around the events of Thor,
Love and Thunder,
so we're into late year 2025 now.
His voice over while he's having that
funny watch is saying hello
to people walking down
the street is him in the book reading?
Reading from the book itself.
After Avengers Endgame, he leverages
his celebrities saving the world
to sell this book,
and he's just been doing that ever since.
When he starts
talking about the Avengers time heist
mission, that's actually been public
knowledge for a while.
Like the whole world knows
most of what the Avengers did in Infinity
War and Endgame with the Time heist.
They even know about Captain America's
other time heist
at the end to return the Infinity stones
they stole from the past.
You notice on the little kids backpack
here, the picture is actually from
a real life poster that Marvel Studios
released for the first Ant-Man movie.
The Shopkeeper makes that funny Spider-Man
reference, confusing
his animal themed Avengers,
mostly because he's a huge Spider-Man fan.
Because at the end of the movie,
when he learns that it's actually Ant-Man,
he makes them pay like, No,
no, only Spider-Man drinks are free.
That's also a bit of a real life
joke about Spider-Man just being a way
more popular character in real life
and in the MCU,
which is meant to flow
with the whole theme of the book.
Look out for the little guy,
like the underappreciated guy,
Jimmy Woo gets a cameo scene
where they each joke about their close up
magic skills because he's gotten super
good at it since Wandavision
They pay off the Baskin-Robbins jokes with
them, naming him employee of the Century
for saving the universe in Avengers
Endgame.
Baskin-Robbins
definitely found out about that.
His former boss has always been played
by Gregg Turkington here.
He's actually a comedian in real life.
This done Marvel parodies of the movies
with Tim Heidecker and one of their shows.
So it's kind of a meta cameo
in the MCU for him.
Hope Van Dyne is taking
control of her father's company
and she's using it to cure
a lot of real world
problems like deforestation, world
hunger, affordable
housing by using pym particles
to just grow small things really large,
like growing food, super huge
so that it will feed a ton of people.
Her newer version of the Wasp
suit is a little bit different
and her haircut are meant to make her look
more like comic book wasp.
That's
what the whole short haircut was about.
The suit along with Cassie Lang's
stinger suit, also have energy based wings
now, whereas before the older suits like
Janet Van Dyne suit had mechanical ones,
also her taking back
Hank Pym company was meant to be a teaser
for Darren Cross returning as Modok
because in the first movie
he controlled the company.
The funny thing about his book here
is that Marvel
actually is selling this as a real book.
You can actually buy this
also a best selling author,
and now you
can purchase my his very real book.
Look out for the little guy.
That's right.
This once movie
prop is now an actual real life book
you can purchase wherever books are sold.
How's that for meta?
In this new book,
I'm almost certain was not written by me.
If anyone's actually purchased it,
let me know in the comments.
The whole line
about missing a bunch of birthdays in
the book
is meant to set at the end of the movie
when he throws
the fake birthday party
with the Baskin-Robbins
ice cream cake, which tastes terrible
because his former boss made it
and he's a terrible cook.
The line
There's always room to grow is also meant
to set up the final fight in the movie
when he encapsulated Grow Giant Size
and Attack Kang's Principle and city.
Hank Pym also says the line, too
There's always room to grow,
but it's meant to be kind of ironic.
Like, I can't believe
I read your entire book cover to cover.
He picks Cassie
Lang up from the local prison and reveals
that he's been in there three times.
She's now been in there twice.
This time
she was arrested for messing with cops
that were going
after a bunch of homeless people
that were protesting peacefully.
They want that to be a big teaser
for what's happening with the resistance
versus Kang.
It's meant to be a big parallel
because they lost their homes to Kang.
They also use a lot of her arc
in the science that she's been working on
in the quantum realm.
Quantum energy to tease young Avengers.
They used a lot of Marvel Phase four to
introduce young Avengers base characters.
I don't know if they're going
to bring the team together
before Cane Dynasty or it's going to be
after secret Wars or something like that.
But eventually we will see the team form.
When she's explaining
why she got thrown in prison,
she also makes another Avengers
endgame reference,
claiming
that the homeless people are only homeless
because they lost their homes in the blip.
And that's actually a direct reference
to Spider-Man far from home,
because that's
what happened to me and Spider-Man.
They came back after the bullet, but
somebody had moved into their former home.
I believe the jail cell
that she was thrown in is also meant to be
the same jail cell that Ant-Man was thrown
in during the first movie.
She's basically meant to be a chip off
the old block.
So, like,
expect her to get into as much trouble
as Ant-Man has gotten into
in all of his movies.
They explained that while all of them
had been snapped, she started reading
from Hank Pym journals, learning
about the quantum realm, quantum energy.
Then when they were all blip back,
she started working with Hank Pym.
Pym particles also eventually wear off,
so eventually the cop car
that she shrunk would grow to full size.
Hopefully it wasn't sitting
inside the station when it grew Back
When he plays his book on tape,
reading in his voice,
he makes the whole baby reference
the time they tried to figure out time
travel in Avengers Endgame.
And in that moment, all I could think was
How did the Hulk
turn me into a baby, baby, baby forever?
Am I the Hulk? Baby?
But since then, we've also met scarred
Son of Hulk
in the She-Hulk series,
who is actually Hulk's baby.
He references Rocket Raccoon,
which I think is also meant to be a soft
reminder that the Guardians of the Galaxy
three movie is going to be Marvel's
next movie that they released this year.
Hank Pym explains his advanced ants
that he's been experimenting with.
He's upgraded them with some tech
and help them get smarter and develop
their own advanced society.
When they all get sucked
into the quantum realm,
they pass through a time dilation field
which causes them to age
over a thousand years.
So by the time they find Hank
later in the movie,
their culture has advanced
like a thousand years.
That's why they're able to fix the ship.
That's why they're so powerful.
Cassie Lang activates her quantum beacon.
That's like a two way radio for
locating things using the quantum realm.
It can basically find
pretty much anything.
So it'll probably come in
handy in future movies
like Young Avengers movies or series.
So remember this device?
It was actually daring Cross Modok
who detected her first signal
when she turned it on? Who alerted Kang?
And Kang used his tech
to pull them into the quantum realm
so he could force Ant-Man
to get his multiverse engine.
The reason he couldn't do it before,
and this is one of the few things
I question
in the movie, is that Kang needed them
because he didn't have Pym particles.
But you'd think that someone so advanced
like was such hyper tech from
the 30th century
would be able to recreate Pym particles.
All the blue energy that you see Kang
using in Kang's
Tech using is his own refinement
of quantum energy.
Like it's all based on quantum energy.
All of Kang's portals at the end
are meant to look exactly like Reed
Richards of the A38 Universe portal.
They're also similar to the TVA portals
that he who
remains had them using in the new variants
of Kang and Loki Season two.
It's all based on quantum energy,
just different implementations
of quantum energy when they're actually
traveling down into the quantum realm.
The sequence is actually meant
to be a reference to Alice in Wonderland
when she's been taken down
into Wonderland,
passing by things that used to be small
but are now much bigger
because she's gotten smaller.
The whole vibe of the movie is
meant to be Honey, I Shrunk the Kids mixed
with Alice in Wonderland,
The Wizard of Oz, and a bit of Star Wars,
like the Quantum Realm would be like the
Land of Oz and Kang would be the Wizard.
They even use Elton John's good bye Yellow
Brick Road song on one of the trailers
When he tells Cassie that they always
talked about going camping together.
That was in the earlier Ant-Man movies
when she was still a little kid
and they would pretend to have adventures
saving the world together.
The energy based creature
that tries to consume
them is a reference to Fantastic Voyage.
When they shrink down to the human body
and get attacked by the immune system,
the beings that they encounter
are Marvel's version of the Microbots.
They couldn't call them that
because Hasbro owns the copyrights
to Microbots in the Microbus.
So that's why they call it
the quantum realm in quantum beings.
Jenny Van Dyne explains
how the quantum realm works.
It's like an entire alternate
universe, separate from space and time
protected from changes at the timeline
in the Council of Kangs
sabotaged Kang's ship and stranded him,
there is a makeshift prison,
but the whole idea is that there's meant
to be one quantum realm
for the entire multiverse,
like it connects to all different
universes In the multiverse,
when the creature grabs them,
the creature is just called holes.
It's actually voiced by David
Dastmalchian,
who played Kurt in the previous movies.
He eventually also gets holes in his body
at the end of the movie.
Being so fascinated with humanoids in
all their holes.
Kaz is played by William Jackson Harper.
He's a totally new character.
He's not like a version of Quasar
or anything like that.
They mostly use him for comedy
because he can read minds and just jokes
that everybody thinks disgusting thoughts.
Janet Van Dyne calls
Hank Pym Ant-Man again
because they're the original Ant-Man
and the Wasp.
When they go back to Ant-Man,
drinking the ooze from Hole's body,
the glowing head alien sitting around him
look just like the colors
of the infinity stones.
Like they're almost like walking infinity
stones.
The funny thing about that is that
the actual infinity stones are alive.
They do have a consciousness
when they're chanting in their language,
they're saying Boone to Eve.
That's actually from Star Wars
Boon to Eve was the name of Manikins
Pod Race and Phantom Menace.
It was called the Boonta Eve Classic,
just like a regular holiday On tattooing.
The goblet that he winds up swilling
the ooze from is also something
they're selling in real life at Disney,
The Avengers campus, like Disneyland
and Disney World.
So you can drink all the ooze you want
from that too.
This character is Jyn Tura.
She's meant to be a princess
in the quantum realm.
From before Kang arrived,
one of the leaders of the resistance,
she names him Kang the Conqueror.
So it sounds like
he was just going by the name
Kang before he came to the quantum realm
and conquered it.
We meet Bill Murray,
who's playing Thriller from the comics.
He was a villain from the Microburst,
but he was green skinned.
In the movie.
He claims he's only humanoid
but not full human.
He and Janet Van Dyne had a relationship
which they play for a joke.
Hank Pym also revealing that he had
a fling with another woman named Linda.
I wonder what happened to Linda cry
Large death also winds up being ironic
because he winds up being eaten
by the very type of creature
that he himself had just eaten,
because they use this part of the movie
for a lot of Star Wars vibes Fellowship
also remind you of the Naboo star
Cruiser in Phantom Menace.
You notice that the ship and probably
all of Kang's ships are powered
using engines that look similar
to the one he uses to power his multiverse
drive only much more primitive power.
Sources.
We see Cassie Lang use the stinger suit
for the first time when Kang's
army attacks.
Her powers
are basically the same as the wasp.
She can also fly, grow large,
daring cross Modok shows up
and he's pretty close
to the appearance of comic book mode.
I just like a little bit different.
His teeth
aren't quite that big in the comics.
Obviously they changed his backstory
for this movie.
In the comics, Modok was George Tarleton,
whose father ran AME,
who experimented on his son, turning him
into Modok, but it was with a C.
The acronym started out
being mental mobile mechanized organism
designed only for computing.
But then he went mad, took over
AIM and renamed himself Modok with a K,
which stood for killing Patton.
Osborn also played a version
of the character on the Modok TV show
that they did a little while ago.
Fire up the machine.
He can't take anymore.
It'll kill him in the MCU, they explained.
The daring cross out to the first Ant-Man
movie accident
caused his body to partially shrink, slit
his head, just wound up being way bigger
than the rest of his body.
Crash in the quantum realm where Kang
found him and upgraded him in exchange
for his service.
Ever since then, he's just been obsessed
with getting revenge on Ant-Man.
They mostly use the character for comedy.
There are a couple of comments
on my previous Ant-Man videos
where it seemed like people didn't
pick up on that.
Like, No, no, no,
they're actually doing this on purpose.
It's supposed to be really tongue
in cheek.
When Janet is flashing back to Kang's
first escape attempt,
he claims he won't destroy her universe
in exchange for helping him escape.
But that was probably only temporary.
Eventually, under him,
things would probably resemble
a similar situation
to the sacred timeline, and he remains
where they only allowed
one version of Kang to exist himself.
When Kang meets Ant-Man
for the first time,
they make a bunch of Avengers references
to Kang's history with The Avengers
from different universes.
I don't know who you are,
but you've made a big mistake.
Okay.
I'm an Avenger.
They've called the other Avengers
the old Avenger.
Have I killed you?
For what?
They all blew together after a while.
You're not the one with the hammer.
It's Thor.
We get confused a lot. Similar body types.
He mentions Thor.
He's killed versions of the Avengers
in every universe he's been do.
That's how he got his scars
when he tells Ant-Man
that if he doesn't get out,
everyone could die.
This is the big teaser for Avengers,
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
because he knows how the multiverse ends,
how time ends.
It's a reference to the events
of Kang Dynasty, with the incursions,
the Kang Multiverse
War reality slowly destroying itself,
and then it turning into secret wars
with battle world where
all of reality collapses
into one single world.
Also, the events of the Loki series,
like I said earlier, where he who remains
variant rises
up, increase the sacred timeline again,
but then he winds up dying
in more incursions.
Start happening.
The Council of Kangs rise up again
and you still wind up
heading towards Avengers Kang Dynasty.
And it seems like his plan, at least
at the moment, is to pull off Thanos.
But for the entire multiverse,
he wants to save the timelines
and universes that he considers safe,
like prevent reality from being destroyed,
but get rid of the ones that are threats.
It's also a reference to destroying
the Council of Kangs entirely,
which he calls the dynasty of kangs.
That's like the first thing on his list.
Like,
I'm going to destroy those that exiled me.
I will erase them from time.
But that's basically them
telling you that Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty is the new Avengers
versus the Council of Kangs,
or the most powerful ones, at least like
Immortals from a scarlet Centurion.
They'll be a bunch others
during Loki Season two,
when he tells Cassie Lang
he doesn't live in a straight line.
That's a reference to his backstory
in the comics.
He also knows
Cassie Lang from earlier in his life.
He jumps all over the timeline as he ages,
so you'll have the very young version
of him pretending to be Iron Lad
fighting with Cassie in the other
young Avengers in present day.
That's how he knows Cassie Lang.
Then the slightly older
twentysomething version of him goes back
to ancient Egypt, becoming Rama Tut
fighting the Fantastic Four.
Then a slightly older version of him
comes back to present day as Kang
the Conqueror fighting The Avengers.
Then again
he turns into the Scarlet Centurion,
so on, so forth, until the ages up
into the Immortals version of himself.
One of the differences in the MCU, though,
from the comic book version
is that because we're talking
about multiverse here
with a bunch of different variants,
is it usually the different kangs
start out being called Nathaniel Richards
that they're born Nathaniel Richards,
and then they take a name
when they come to power.
Instead of taking a bunch of different
names, they just take one different name.
In this particular one took the name Kang.
The other thing about Kang
is that he also interacts with himself
at different points in his own timeline,
and all the different variants do this.
So you'll have like
the older version of himself
trying to help
the younger version of himself
give him advice or technology or weapons.
In a lot of times
the different versions of him
from different parts of his own timeline
will disagree with each other.
So like the young version of Kang
will want to listen
to the older version of himself.
And when he says, There's a lot of me
that are coming, that's in saying that
the future events of Avengers Kang Dynasty
are going to be the Council of Kangs
coming to kill all of them
when they start talking
about the multiverse engine, explaining
how it works.
He talks about the probability storm
when they go down there,
a bunch of variants of Ant-Man
and the Wasp pop up and then disappear.
The whole concept of manipulating
probability is how the engine allows
Kang to travel across the timeline, across
different universes.
But part of the idea is
the longer you're down there, the greater
the chances that you'll go mad.
And at the end of the movie,
Kang essentially gets sucked
into that probability storm.
So it is possible that he will return
in Avengers Kang Dynasty or in Secret
Wars is a more powerful version of himself
who's even crazier.
There've been a lot of rumors
about what's happening with Secret Wars,
like it's going to be different villains
between Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
So if they're going
to fight the Council of Kangs in Kang
Dynasty, wouldn't this version of Kang,
who still wants to kill them, return
at the end of that movie,
kill them and then go on to create
Battle World for Secret Wars?
Because at the very end of the film
it says Kang will return.
It doesn't say Kang's multiple,
but return is as one.
Kang will return.
But it is kind of meant to be a tongue
in cheek
reference to the Council of Kang's
because every version of them will return.
I just think the way they worded
that statement is meant to be ambiguous.
So you're like,
Wait a minute, maybe he didn't die.
When they're down inside the core,
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs.
The core itself looks similar to Shang.
She's ten rings of Power.
The writing on the Rings also looks like
celestial symbols, which we also saw
in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
in the Darkhold Temple.
I think the whole idea here
is that Kang in the 30th century
started using celestial technology
to enhance his designs
because celestials are the most advanced
beings in the universe.
Of course you try to use celestial tech
if you could.
In fact, the Rama version of Kang
when he escaped the Fantastic Four
and left the past, he actually designated
Apocalypse as his successor.
Apocalypse
formed a new bargain with the Celestials
to get their technology, which is how
he got his advanced ship in his armor.
When all the anime and variants
start popping up.
Most of them are the same
with the exception
of the version of Scott Lang,
who never became Ant-Man and still
just kept working at Baskin-Robbins.
His name is Jack,
which is a reference to Jack Kirby,
who co-created the character
with Stan Lee and Larry Lieber.
When they all start working together,
that's a reference to ant colonies
working together to form bridges
or ladders like it's an army of ant men.
After Modok attacks Hank Pym, he's
rescued by his advanced ants, who are now
a thousand years more developed in hyper
advanced with more technology
than Kang explains his grand plan
for the multiverse.
How time is broken.
But he and his variance broke it
so he's going to try and fix it.
That's basically
by killing the Council of Kangs
because he thinks that they're the ones
that are actually in the process
of breaking it even worse.
Then go Thanos on the entire multiverse
and just kill a portion of the timelines
that he thinks are dangerous.
They give rise to dangerous kang variants,
kind of like what he remains did
when he talks about burning
the broken world and making a new one.
I also think that's another battle world
reference to secret wars,
which is another clue that he might return
as the villain for secret wars.
And when he says he's lost
more than Janet, can imagine, he's
probably talking about Ravonna, Renslayer, his love interest from the comics,
because Kang's whole thing is helping
younger versions of himself.
Earlier in his own timeline, he explains
that an even older version of himself
told him once when he was super drunk,
taking him to the future, showing him
the death of a woman speaking her name.
It was Ravonna  Renslayer.
She dies in front of them.
And then this older version of Kang
that was trying to advise
the younger version
goes off and weeps in a corner, speaks her
name once, and then never speaks again.
So her death is meant to be
this huge tragedy.
In Kang's backstory, there is a version
of Raven Translator on the Loki series.
The version that escaped at
the end of season two was given orders by
he who remains about how to survive
the rebooted timeline.
So that version will come back in season
two and be one of the characters
that actually remembers the events
of season one like Loki and Sylvie.
I'm hoping
we actually get to see some scenes
with her and Jonathan Majors
as a variant of Kang on screen.
When Kang tries to escape
the quantum realm,
he tries to take his entire crew
novel in the city
because it contains his army
like he's taking his dynasty with him.
You notice the rings around the giant city
itself are meant to be the same concept
as the rings around his smaller ship
image and goes for Leroy
Jenkins on Kang Turning giant size
and just making a run at Kannapolis.
He makes a big Captain America reference
using one of the circular platforms
as a giant shield like Captain America
Shield, blocking the weapons
fire is also a reference to holding
Captain America's Shield during Civil War,
which he referenced earlier,
correcting that that he didn't fight
Captain America at the airport.
He helped him
hold winds up getting all of his holes.
Turns out he can consume things
using them.
Cassie Lang fights Modok and convinces him
that it's never too late
to stop being a dick.
And he helps them defeat
Kang Dying in Avenger in the process.
R.I.P.
They play that for a huge gag
with everyone
just humoring him like, Sure, buddy.
Sure. You're
definitely on the Avengers team now.
Cassie also winds up going giant sized,
which is another reference
to her time in stature
on the Young Avengers.
Ant-Man makes a big Godzilla reference
when they hug and when she starts
complaining about being hungry,
needing citrus, all of a sudden
that's a callback to all the times
that Ant-Man has gone Giant Man.
In previous movies,
he said similar things.
When Kane joins the fight, you notice
one of his abilities
is to rewind the energy blast in time so
that it destroys the resistance fighter.
They're just showing him
how precise his control over time
is when they fail to kill him.
The first time he taunts them, saying it's
not the first time that he's faced
rebellions or Avengers like this.
He's killed Avengers
in every single universe he's been too.
That's why he's still standing here.
He almost winds up escaping
through Janet's portal, but Hope winds up
getting him sucked into the multiverse.
Drive like I said, potential
that he survived that somehow
and will return by Avengers
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
It's one of those traditional Marvel
comic book movie explainers.
If you don't see a body, it's
no confirmation of death.
When things slowly go back to normal.
Then the ending joke about him
suddenly remembering
Kang's warning about the Council of Kangs
in Kang Dynasty Secret Wars, then shrugs
it off like it's no big deal. Like,
you know what?
That's not going to be anything.
Let's not worry about it.
The coffee shop
owner figures out who he is and starts
making him pay for his coffee
because he's not Spider-Man.
Apparently he's
just a really big Spider-Man. Stan.
He throws the fake birthday party
for Cassie with the terrible tasting
aunt themed
ice cream cake from Baskin-Robbins
paying off the line
from earlier in the movie.
In the book,
in a very than a much longer video on both
the post-credits scenes to all link it
at the end of this the Mid-Credits scene,
the post-credits scene
teasing the Council of Kangs decided
to take action against the Avengers
and other people from universes
that have started to touch the multiverse.
They're talking about other people
like Clea from the Dark Dimension, the A3
eight Universe Avengers
who survive the Illuminati,
the Scarlet Witch killed like Superior
Iron Man.
There are a lot of other characters,
like from the Fox Marvel Universe.
There's Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man,
Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man.
A lot of those people will come back
during Secret wars,
some of them like Wolverine and Deadpool.
We'll see.
Before that, though,
they're really making it
sound like Deadpool three is going to be.
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
and it'll be like a big turning point
In the lead up to Avengers
Cain Dynasty were a bunch of incursions
wind up happening?
I'll put a link for that Post-Credits
scene video
at the end of this
and down to the description below.
During that I explain all the different
kang variants that appear.
There are thousands
in the Post-Credits scene,
but only about ten or 15 major ones.
The second Post-Credits scene
is more of a teaser for Loki Season two,
with Loki and Mobius
seeing the Victor timely variant of Kang.
Explain a little bit more about
what's going on during that
and what it means during that video.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references
in the movie
that I didn't mention in this video
or in my other post-credits scene video,
just write them in the comments below.
Loki Season two will be the next place
we see variants of Kang.
They'll be doing stuff like this,
going on missions,
trying to stop the Council of Kangs
in addition to going on regular missions,
stopping other variants and Nexus events.
Everyone click here for that
Post-Credits scene video and click here
for my Loki Season two trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.